day one of reopening for bars here
locally the state closed bars that don't
serve food over two months ago to slow
the spread of the coronavirus
they're back open just in time for
monday night football hector mejia live
near charleston and rainbow with how one
of those bars is preparing hey hector
getting all comfy on the couch hey there
alex
yeah comfy and i am ready i have my seat
here so uh
you know business orders have been
waiting for this for quite some time the
covet 19 task force says
transmission rates dropped enough to
allow a lot of the places that have been
closed
to reopen and here at the tavern they
have plenty of space for social
distancing
it's a sports bar and they are
anticipating crowds later on of course
with social distancing
but this place however has been open but
they've had to make a lot of changes to
adjust and
be able to open or to stay open and
joining us live here we have ginger
general manager here at the tavern to
explain
you know today's a huge day for a lot of
business owners across not only the
valley but the state
yeah we've been really looking forward
to it obviously it's been a process and
kind of a waiting process on our end
but we are very excited to have everyone
in today and be part of las vegas
history with the raiders first home game
exciting day you guys already have some
customers in here this early in the
morning
we do we always have we have a lot of
local people it's their home so
they come all hours of the day and night
to kind of just enjoy our company enjoy
the environment we created
speaking of environment it could be and
it is a special place for many describe
what the tavern is all about the vibe
here the tavern is just home in a place
where you can
um be yourself and be enjoyed and we
have all different types of people in
this part of town and they all get along
together
and they're they're friends they're
family and we all care about each other
the same
so the last question can you sort of you
know describe from your perspective what
it was like during the darkest of the
days during the thick of the pandemic
yeah it's been difficult i've been doing
this for a long time out of college and
turned it into a career
we never thought or i would have never
seen this happening so
it's been dark days it's been times when
we wondered if this industry would come
back or at all so it's still it's going
to be a process but we're excited to see
the forefront of it
getting back into motion thank you so
much for having us this early in the
morning
thanks for having us alright reporting
live hector mejia 8 news now back to you
guys